no longer shared kin or blood but two
hostile Nations at War that's how leader
Kim junga now describes North Korea's
view of South Korea countries once W
split into two when the lead up to the
Cold War eight decades
ago see as they call us their main enemy
and collude with foreign powers we
should no longer make the mistake of
considering South Korea a partner for
reconciliation and
unification it's a concerning
development for soul which strongly
condemned North Korea's hostile stance
he's basically said that although we are
still one people that the South Koreans
are puppets of capitalism especially the
United States and he has given up
dealing with the South Koreans
peacefully at the conclusion of its
yearend key party meeting North Korea
vowed also to intensify its production
of nuclear weapons and military drones
that's says other powers strongly
suspect it is strengthening military
cooperation with Russia this year
Pyongyang speedily developed its solid
fueled Hong 18 intercontinental
ballistic missile after a record five
launches of icbms it also claimed to
have sent its first functioning military
spy satellite into Earth's orbit with
three more planned in the New Year the
conservative Yuna government has
emphasized that peace is earned through
military strength dismissing his
predecessor's policy of Engagement with
the north as fake pieace reliant on the
enemy's Goodwill South Korea has
recently engaged in high-profile
military drills with Japan and the
United States and analysts say that
pyongyang's ruling out of a peaceful
reunification is its attempt to
legitimize the use of nuclear weapons
against South Korea as Washington
deploys strategic assets more frequently
in the region and elections loom in 2024
analysts warn pongyang could find new
reasons to respond more aggressively in
the coming months Unis Kim Al jazer
Soul make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz